what's up kid welcome to fighter and the
kids with jeremiah watkins one of my
boys has a new special that just dropped
on amazon check it out
they got vinyl cd uh go find it jeremiah
watkins one of my favorite people on the
planet is here this episode and he's
bringing wigs it gets ridiculous
before we get into it this crew the fire
in the kids is in san marcos texas all
tickets almost sold out again
there will be no comps we can't do extra
tickets none of that stuff
what we have is what we have the tickets
are going fast january 29th through the
30th
uh san marcos texas we're outside austin
right south san antonio
it's at the mark all right and tickets
are still available
but they're going to be sold out so get
them while you can right now i think
it's in like two weeks
two weeks we'll be in san marcos texas
january 29th through the 30th
tickets at tfatkay.com or
fatkz.com our new website check it out
san marcos texas let's ride this episode
of fire and the kids is brought to you
by on it
on it.com slash fighter 10 percent off
everything you need to hit your goals
for down 21.
what do you need new mood alpha brain
krill oil
joint oil earth grow nutrients shroom
tech
we got creatine glutamine we got it all
man electrolytes
we got fitness gear free ass kello bells
we got streaming on demand fitness with
on it six barbell body weight fitness
on it in 30 kettlebell workouts on it
and 30 morning mobility
on it in 30 move and groove on demand
workout so you don't have to go to the
gym
do it from your freaking couch and your
undies you can get in shape with on it
let them
guide you through your fitness journey
whatever you need kettlebells steel
maces
steel clubs battle ropes yoga mats we
got it all on it.com slash fighter 10
off
t-5k put a z
[Music]
yeah i'm ready to start chin yeah we're
full of uh
bootleg pizza shout out to bootleg
donating these delicious pizzas to the
crib
to the studio studio to the whole squad
jeremiah watkins in
in the house yeah
[Music]
right good answer good answer yeah yeah
service has never done them
survey says uh bootleg pizza
better than prince i like mine take the
racism out of it
take racism at it take yelp reviews i
was already thinking yeah yeah [ __ ] that
that's their that's their life they
could be rich
yeah um bootleg man god it was nice
it was really nice real good you've
never had friends i've never had prince
before what's your favorite pizza in la
though
uh lucifers oh you like blue i love it
yeah the hot pizza
it's hot sauce pizza yeah yeah it's so
spicy
really good that sounds i like lucifer's
and joe's oh joe's about to go
yeah joe's good and then uh we used to
go there live have you had gelena
takeaway
uh no no no off abbott single slices
only
that thing's gonna cost you 60 bucks for
a full pie now that's like really
well that's how expensive it is it's
nice though hmm
that's a so bootlegs up there man
definitely top top three for me that was
fantastic that was it that's really
that's right and what's weird is i'm a
pepperoni guy the cheese was better than
the pepperoni yeah cheese
because you like it sausage saucy daddy
yeah
okay double down on
no one's going to back you up with a
saucy dab i like your sausage i like it
come on just put it on my chest real
quick you're saying it like a twink
though dude
i say it more like a beer you know like
what uh how's this uh quarantine been
treating you dude
uh before we started rolling i i really
felt like it i was having a birthday
party because like this is
i haven't had pizza with friends like
this it's so long like it's
crazy right get this vibe yeah yeah
yeah but it's a shame it's weird uh i've
been i've been torn a little bit like i
have you yeah i was just in fort worth
at hyenas and then i was in austin texas
texas um but before that i was like in
minneapolis i did like kentucky like
i've been doing like random spots
like around yeah like different weekends
and stuff like that comedy caravan
in kentucky off broadway coming off
broadcasting yeah yeah oh yeah
how was it out there it was good uh you
just have to
certain places you have to protect
yourself a little bit more i just i
haven't been doing the meet and greet so
i've been doing like uh like a q a
segment i don't think anybody's gonna
meet in grades
i don't think it's smart too right now
like i think everybody gets it you tell
people i'm like i got a wife pregnant at
home like was your girl pregnant yeah
yeah first one
yeah thank you
we don't do a lot of clapping on podcast
yeah malik's the guy who's trying to
start the slow class
you know what sucks right behind them
like dude all right continue with your
story now i'm just going to dab you up
he's pregnant so you don't want to get
but you haven't had covet i haven't had
it no
i have i have the antibodies though so
maybe i did have oh
oh yeah yeah yeah like i had the
antibodies like uh
five months ago oh you're fine get a
jail free card yeah
yeah yeah but i've been trying to you
know
it's nice to still go out and like feel
like a comic though
because i know a lot of comics no a lot
of comics are just doing the zoom shows
right now and i can't do those i just
yeah i've made it this far on the
pandemic without doing a zoom shot i'm
just going to power through it
yeah i refuse to do there's no point
especially for you because you're super
animated on stage
yeah i give so much yeah i'm like i
i i don't know i feel super
self-conscious be like yeah
people just like in this little zoom
like a nightmare
yeah be pretty rough yeah so you just
been so
uh wifey's just at home you guys are a
lot you guys are in hollywood
uh just south of hollywood no well yeah
we recently moved just a little bit
south of hollywood yeah man what's
scared about
la is when you don't realize how locked
down la is till you get
out and about like we're always florida
people in restaurants and [ __ ] i'm like
you [ __ ] savages dude in fort worth
i went to grab uh pizza at this uh place
called zalat the next time you go there
it's really good late night pizza eatery
um
and there was a full-on nightclub going
on like a couple
like shops down and that was just kind
of crazy to experience because i'm like
like in la everything's just so shut
down and then you can't even have a
night club if you want it
no peter and then people were letting
out it at two o'clock and i had my
luggage going to the airport and i was
getting heckled as
i was rolling my life like where are you
going
because it's going to the airport it's
like like why that fool got a suitcase
yeah what's happening utah had uh the
gloves open too
popping we were scooters yeah we're what
are they called someone got shot the
yeah someone got shot um birds well
we're on birds the bird
the bird pops we strolled by this
straight club there's a line out there
bro
lying out the door given these mormons
didn't give a
[ __ ] getting lit drinking too they were
drinking yeah right
real housewives oh man they were
drinking probably doing butt stuff
yeah ending with gunshots well you know
what soaking it up
soaking yeah yep yep it's where
uh basically it doesn't count if you
leave just your penis in but you don't
give
just the tip it's no no you put the
whole penis in but you just leave it
there it's a glory hole
no no no no no it's like or whatever
so you leave it in and it's just like
baking the pizza
baking the pizza and then point what a
nightmare it's just
you just want to feel that that warm
wetness i guess oh that's weird
this is weird you just leave it in it's
called the soak soaking
oh no yeah yeah why i mean because that
doesn't count
i guess encounters are not thrown
because you're not thrust them yeah
there's not effort being put into it so
you just leave it
and then just live in it these kids
these days
kids these days i didn't see that i
didn't
i think they call it soaking yeah yeah
it's weird
i'm a super soaker man that's what i do
this summer
so other than that you just been torn
and chilling man you made a you dropped
the [ __ ]
special yeah yeah it's out now on amazon
prime uh you can rent it or uh purchase
it and then yeah i've got some copies on
vinyl that i brought you on
i like the vinyl vibes man i like that
yeah you look terrified on the front
that's the point that's the point was
that you were your mom
yeah it was uh unexpected family reunion
that happened at that show so that's
where did you film this back in kansas
city in december of uh
20 is that a newer club uh it is yeah it
just opened recently my buddy uh dustin
kaufman runs it yeah
yeah so you filmed it during a pandemic
how how was the crowd
uh before like right before so it was uh
oh just sometimes
yeah yeah a few months before yeah right
before oh so it's normal
so now have you just been sitting on it
and decided to release it now yeah so i
was i was planning on putting together
like a i do like a lot of riffing and
crowd work in my act
and i was thinking about putting
together like a park crowd work part
doc with my family and then the pandemic
hit and i had all this material that
i've been sitting on forever and i'm
like
let's just release it like i have like i
shot it like it was working there like
it's i knew that it would take me as a
comic you know how it takes you a while
to get your reps up where
you're like hitting on that stuff all
the time and it's not feeling rusty i'm
like
this was when i was touring all the time
so i was like
i want to release this now yeah because
you if you did special now be tough man
i'm on the more touring comics during
this coat which shouldn't
i mean maybe twice a month you can get
out well it's weird because like we have
to work out stuff on the road now rather
than like
little shows around town and that's a
different
muscle altogether working off like yeah
a crowd like completely
trying to put stuff in there where
you're like i know this next one's going
to hit
let me sneak in a full hour and you've
had like yeah it is when you're
when la's popping you're getting up damn
three four nights a week and then you're
hitting the road
yeah now it's like yeah you feel ready
that's like two months off let me go
run this hour oh it's like oh man
yeah yeah it's intense dude seriously
well that's it that's our podcast
well that was good anyways hey i showed
you some hair
you didn't have to have the fans been
hanging out about your hair
uh no they don't give a [ __ ] no no i
i've
given people like you should try this
try this try this oh really yeah but i'm
like there's a bunch of white guys
yeah try this out yeah i know i'm
look at that right there bro that's uh
okay how old am i right there i'm uh
it's a young wesley snide yeah is that a
is that a cast picture
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how long ago is that oh dude i think it
was 1974
1970 come on book them
no i think i was like 17 or 18 right
there
or something like that just so yeah it
had to be like oh that might have been
like
oh four that [ __ ] was dope chin you got
the picks
uh the rest of the like yeah i could
braid that length i could braid it
nah bro you have no hell no longer than
that
[ __ ] about black people's hair that has
to be long enough
the rainbow here that's his real hair
when you dye your hair that much it's so
damaged that it probably is fake like
most people
almost with all those colors made your
hair there's no problem
exactly because then your hair starts to
fall out the more you dye it because the
more you bleach it it just kills and
kills
okay brian johnson
oh shout out to brian johnson i'll tell
you what i'm not mad at the
top one last one number three looks like
a gay man
that looks like a sauce daddy
daddy
number three he pulled up in an old ford
explorer
[Applause]
number four is [ __ ] saucy that is
saucy let's
scroll down yeah i like number eight
number four number five
number four looks like the gel no number
eight's more ordeal
number four also looks like uh the
weekend's broke cousin the worker
the work week yeah a weekend's broke
cousin
over time just not doing well in life
yeah
hey i was doing well in life in that
picture i like number six see like a
migo lately
oh no no no that's like a millie vanilla
yeah
that is just not the vibe you know what
it's going to take nine years to get bro
what about number 10
but imagine 10 without that [ __ ] rat
tail in the back
kind of kind of dope nah you're plugging
your cds on hollywood boulevard for sure
would that look right
number 10 yeah yeah oh no you're awesome
you're off venice bull
you're off venice board you're like you
like hip-hop you like
putting on the headphones yeah what
about 12 what the hell is that
what the hell 12 come on brian johnson
maybe i was 11 looks kind of dope too
left hitting a point
about this that's class act right there
it's not even house party well i think
out of all these that i think number
four hits the hardest number four hits
the heart number number three hits the
hardest yeah
number three is great yeah you look like
somebody drunk uncle number three it's
like a lenny kravitz well that's lenny
kravitz
that's not good i don't know it looks
like you're filling in for dave matthews
urban outfitter
[Laughter]
i like the best one that clearly is
number one i like one too
yeah that's my original hair that's his
hair yeah that's what i originally go
back to that why are you trying yeah
that might be you know what you're
probably right yeah what about going
back to that
what are we doing here no you don't
think number one's better than uh
this no okay i was a psycho
that's right number one oh you what you
got clippers on you right now what'd you
actually no yeah you got
you got the stenches oh [ __ ]
yeah i'm kind of concerned with some
black ones with that [ __ ] on
put it on let's see what we've got huh
look at you transition to sauce daddy
you bout to look like lost daddy
oh damn right down by the beach
oh wow okay girl you know it's true
wow that's all my [ __ ] face
no no i know black girls wear wigs but
black dudes don't wear wigs right
well a couple of them do i'm trying to
understand yeah some of them have you
can rock that
yeah i'm trying i'm seeing it a little
bit a little bit yeah yeah
for real you look like kenny and kel
when they do that burger oh
hello welcome to good burgers my son's
obsessed with that movie from 1997.
what what was such a weird reference
what the [ __ ] we come home
and if he knows that he only gets his
ipad for an hour a day he'll come home
he puts on good burger
are you serious like you're a weird dude
last time you made a good burger
reference none
no never no no seriously what the hell
the secret sauce where i don't i don't
get like this that here just that here
bugged me
that hair just screams i'm late on rent
what i'm saying
that's not it doesn't feel like you have
your [ __ ] can you pull up a picture
take a picture though it like you just
come over girl
is it no doubt don't mind these 12
incense i got lit
it looks like you're gonna invite a girl
over and make her pay for the mail
oh wow there we go oh man i'll take that
damn that [ __ ] is dope right
check this out hold on
hey you get some tits justin might be
into you
any way he can get them
[Music]
that's so funny yeah i mean i brought a
bag full of wigs because i know
cat is always around a bunch of dudes
and i figured
you know what you want us to transition
i got one for brendan oh [ __ ] i'll wear
a wig
okay let's go let's go let's go is this
this wig episode
i do this segment on my podcast
transition on jeremiah wonders we're all
transitioning right now wait hold on
wait what
that's brenda that we're about to see
here all right let's let's see let's see
brittany this okay it's tough yeah
wait don't you already know he's gonna
be hey
sauce daddy
needs better health oh
god hello bro yo chevelle and that
picture looks like he's going to storm
the cowboys
you don't want the world
britney looked like that girl in
hercules uh um
yeah the red header she's back yeah
that's what i'm saying it's a cartoon
dog
she's bad she's a cartoon though wait
wait just happened
and i'm like damn right brother's a full
ass mouth man with that wig that's yeah
yeah yeah that's right why am i blondie
unless you want something else
yeah let me let me go back to my roots
there we go there you go let me get
lucky
i'll go blondie
chin
huh what's your natural color jeremiah
like blondish brownish
it used to be really blonde now it's
like golden brown the la sun
oh damn oh okay damn you look like one
of the backup scenes for ray charles
are you the [ __ ] supremes
in fact get out get out do it myself i'm
gonna do it myself
yeah you know what matter of fact all
you'll get brandon looks like uh that
episode that uh
jessie spano and saved by the belt got
addicted to pills oh [ __ ]
oh he's so excited
damn we some bad [ __ ] though boys i'm
rick james
i don't know about y'all james
uh not rick james
oh my god
you don't
[Applause]
she's looks like the biggest member of
bts who finally transitioned
jim yo you really you rocking it the
best though
yeah that works that somehow works
jeremiah yeah i am i'm i'm not sure why
we're all in wait
whatever man funniest [ __ ] you know
dude let's put a little rouge
then he gets out he's like dude what is
this cocaine
what are we doing here man i love like
how you started the episode i
i feel like i'm at home with my i know
right with the pizza but listen this is
what the show is missing
dudes with wigs let's just transition
listen it's my birthday we're doing
pizza we're gonna win
we believe
we got real pizza bro you said jeff
bella like the one only black person at
the
capitol the steel is real
yeah you're the one black guy boxing
i don't know i i feel like uh i feel
like cat
this could be fighter in the cats
[Applause]
it could be uh you know cat i feel like
um you know like i said you you're
around this testosterone energy all the
time
well yeah like what you want to bounce
some ideas off your girlfriend
you need advice or anything
for your girlfriend do you have any
ideas
[Applause]
goldberg
whoopi goldberg just looked like [ __ ]
just
hate everybody it's great come on oh
whoopi golfing i love whoopi goldwater
is one of my top favorite actors
still oh yeah she's great yeah what's
she been in lately yes
that is the view the view too
the view too okay here we go all right
so i'm sitting i'm sending it to you now
chan all right
here we go all right she killed it in
ghost
she did dawg that girl was fired 30
years ago ghost was fired though
what else did she was she patrick
oh she killed it 35 years she was in
theodore rex you remember that boo
remember that
yeah well she befriended a t-rex
how do you how do you jeremiah 32 32 was
your birthday
uh december 15th oh you just turned 32
yeah
hey girls don't touch each other's
chests like yeah they yeah they do
all the time cat grabs her sister's
titties all the time
oh i'm sorry that's just
that's my that's my male brain girl
get that out of here what the [ __ ]
not my bad girls hanging out here
touching their chest like i think they
do though
i feel like uh chappelle's about to tell
me my fortune
oh yeah no [ __ ] what do you mean i mean
she was severely out of shape
no she wasn't miss cleo miss cleo was
big was she
do you don't you honestly she's still
living you don't have the name no really
don't be
skinny bring miss cleo he's so stupid no
miss cleo no no i think i think covert
got her and if covered
her cholesterol did yeah bring her up
mrs cleo look great
don't pick the yeah i look at her she's
kind of thing call me now for your free
reading
that's what she always said right uh-huh
yeah horrible accent i did i'm sorry
guys
all right she's not too thick there yeah
that's what i'm saying how'd she pass
she's a psychic and i said she didn't
see it coming huh her death oh okay
all right i'll see what you do thank you
i'll be here all weekend
i'm in san marcos uh january 29th 30th
all right these things personal life and
death
colon cancer oh that's sad
okay stop that no not calling to get you
she's
53 oh she was a lesbian was she really
oh yeah she came out in 2006 before was
the cool thing to do i know damn
she was married at 18 19 gave birth to a
daughter divorced age 21 she had a
second daughter
in her late 20s and 206 she came out as
a
lesbian
yeah damn those are the people always uh
that i think are crazy who think about
marriage at 19.
that was that but dude she's 53 back
then that's what let's see one more chan
i'm sorry
50 yeah back then my parents got married
young like yeah how old were your
parents when they got married
my parents were 10 years apart in age
yeah yeah oh really yeah yeah
how was your dad he was i think he was
like
in early 40s when he married my mom i
thought you're gonna say your dad was
like
he's like oh my dad's like 27. no no
my dad was like early 40s early 40s my
mom was early 30s yeah yeah as my dad is
like
70 right late start oh you got that old
dad yeah so he's like 38 yeah
yeah how many siblings you got older
brother younger sister oh just two
guys old dad though old dad yeah you
that middle child but you're
a weird middle child i mean look at us i
know right now
not normal i mean girl i mean
this is a tuesday am i yeah
[Applause]
all right let's read this [ __ ] let me
read this [ __ ] chin hold on he's not he
has like
eight of them they're all in the wrong
order eight of eight too many though
yeah bro just says the best ones don't
sense the one just like dude i'm 14.
just yeah my girl over snapchat it was
where do i go from here
it was one like 33. hold on hmm
that's the one that i seen you that i
just damn dude
[Music]
i didn't know a lot of dudes oh if you
haven't seen it he he thinks he's a love
dog
so now all these people you with that
hat you look like over that wig you look
like a lover yeah he looks like a uh a
rich televangelist who's scamming people
i'm not saying i'm not that's you right
now no i'm not i'm not scamming people
but you have the diamond studs
they might not be in the right order
just tell us which one to go to okay i
just pick anyone though you know
no that's not that's not no we already
stopped showing this guy he said love
these nuts
don't do that this one uh
let's try this one let's try it all
right tyler
dr love dr love no no no no no no no no
we did this one why are you sending i
didn't sit on the old one
how much how many did you send me right
now chin only sent you three with that
hair
one two three
girl girl you better get a hold of
yourself
tighten this [ __ ] up hey all right let's
do this again okay
all right i'll let you know you guys
talk you guys talk no i wanna resend it
again didn't you
no it's gonna it's gonna add more to it
so i'll just get the last three okay so
the first one is man dr love i've been
going through it i'm 33 years old
me and my girl just split on new year's
eve after dating six months
right she said i wanted to go to the new
year
[ __ ] carden just went to the net sorry
[ __ ] your guy how about
how about jim torns just went to the net
jay just text me oh i hate to be shitty
about this
you remember when you got me that kyrie
irving jersey like last week yeah i
remember that i gotta trade it in for a
harden no
it's only fair it's on going away he's
not on the team anymore but but
it's on the wall i don't want an old
jersey what
holy [ __ ] what did they give up yo
so james horn heading to brooklyn this
should do it
lakers versus brooklyn oh dude hondo
purse
anyways uh we are talking about love and
then
there's men in there and in their sports
always
interrupting all the time the round ball
dominates again
hair tie you know what i'm saying you
wanna start with this one yeah let's go
ahead that's the one i was reading go
ahead and read that the hardest of the
nets is crazy i know bro but hold on
i don't want that irving jersey anymore
but irving's still on the team they
didn't trade him um
jay
you keep saying that but if they they
know how to play together can we
reach out are you basketball these
[ __ ]
y'all gonna need that new jersey man
like seriously
don't make me ask again our bets are
batman come on
come on man what's right
hey look i'm saying this we we all can
agree and
you're waiting like sorry yeah i like
how y'all look at joey
malik looks cool
he was like man you driving this
[ __ ] too damn fast
[Laughter]
i was gonna say um kevin durant he all
we all know he can play uh
do well with other superstars yeah it's
kind of reverb yeah it's kyrie irving
that can't do well
now but james harden don't know how to
play well with other superstars as well
look at him and uh russ you see i'm
saying doesn't yeah but russell
brunson kd does so i think and kd
doesn't need as many shots as everybody
else still gets his because he's such a
good
such a great shooter but look at kyrie
if if they can do harden durant and
kyrie they figure it out dog they going
sizzling and you don't think kyrie's
you talk about kyrie's gonna quit he's
not gonna quit that's a jason
again jay bayless this reason why we
call him there come on skip all right
all right let's get into these guys
all right let's see what we got all
right so man dr love go ahead and read
it brittany
bro you funny as hell no no go scroll
down
i want some dust yeah
here we go ah dick pic okay here we go
man dr love i've been going through
it i'm 33 years old and me and my girl
just split on new year's eve after
dating for six months not long at all
uh she said she wanted to go into the
new year with a new slate good for her
she also went to san diego on a trip
with her chick friends on new year's
check friends definitely got dick uh we
never had any arguments prior we thought
she might have been pregnant
ooh the week of christmas until she
finally got her period too much info
uh we were already playing on name for
the kid
and with her living in l.a and me living
in arizona i was already contemplating
moving
my entire life to l.a if we got the news
she was pregnant okay but she's not
i guess she wasn't loving the man i was
becoming any advice
i love this girl and can't lose her
she's already going
um bye
it already happened bye
bye felicia when he said she went on a
trip with her chick friends
yeah on new year's come on you know what
those girls
she wasn't pregnant before she pregnant
one two three dick
is that what they do yeah on a night out
but um hey bro
man trust me yeah they grab their tits
they do the like again
that's right that's what i'm saying
around here like one two three dick
no well cat don't brandon's like who if
i was a [ __ ] that's what i would
there's some out there that might
do uh listen uh what was his name don't
say his name no you can't say that he
can't say his name hey listen dawg
listen she's already gone
yeah you're 33 years old you're pregnant
she's not pregnant it's only six months
your life
thank you six months six months six
months you're in arizona dude the
honey's out there look at your boy here
the honey's out there look at your boy
hey take it from me listen you're going
to be
fine the honey's at z look like jeremiah
let's just get that out the way
you should move to l.a okay and no no
chill in arizona what's his word arizona
dude if you're live
entertainment why the [ __ ] would you
come to this nice
night he's not paying taxes in arizona
yeah he's living life in there
asu is out there i'm telling him his
girl's over it man don't come here
chasing a girl that done once yeah bro
don't chase a girl who got a train right
now she's 33. how do you know she got a
trainer
i thought he said that
brendan reads through the dns a little
differently listen
i skim through it i was with this girl
for 30 years
she had a drain ran on her
oh hell yeah yeah let's have them zoom
wait so real quick with this guy he
actually messaged me too and i actually
felt bad
because he reminds me of someone if you
go to his instagram which we're not
going to show but just to you guys i'll
show
okay he reminds us yeah totally reminds
me of somebody
do you guys notice anything about him
that looks like someone or am i just
tripping
the heart do you think he looks like jay
yeah i love him
wait wait what i think he looks like jay
let me see again not in that
that's a great ovo shirt though yeah
anyways it's not j so
yeah yeah yeah well hey look man find
love bro i see yeah good man stay in
arizona find that love man there's
not being a deal dude yeah yeah yeah i
wouldn't even worry about old girl in la
you don't want l.a jeremiah yo y'all got
so funny oh
i was just looking at brendan i realized
he looks like a disney princess
you look like merida from brave oh
i was looking at something that's the
one with the pet uh chameleon
no that's rapunzel ah [ __ ] different one
only thing is like your wig's a little
off
your hairline is it funny yeah just a
little a little more nothing worse when
that happens
where's she from let my hair grow from
brave yeah i've been i've actually never
seen that
it's pretty good oh no yeah so brave
which is the one with the long hair
uh rapunzel this one but what's that
movie it's not called rapunzel no it's
called tangled
yeah that's right that's what the
chameleons tangle was fire tangle's good
i like tango well yeah you don't have to
put your arm around me but yeah
you can put it back take your wig off
dog start looking like something
from the side you do it like yeah this
one says hey dr love i'm in a new
relationship and feel real happy in it
although i catch myself being jealous
over small things
because i have difficult past
relationship i never bring it up to my
new lady but wondering if you have any
tips on how i can get over jealousy
i still want my insecurities to ruin a
happy relationship
you said it right there brother say
you're not comfortable with yourself
learn who you are as a person again love
yourself first let a man
you're becoming look at your mind he's
like this guy's seriously yeah i'm so
serious
i'm trying to be serious don't don't
distract me i'm on a roll
listen his girl is gonna find him watch
us like this is
okay well who's this uh therapist his
name's dr love
well let's see let's see what he looks
like
and you give me right here you gotta
know who you are
i love the transition that you're trying
to make in your life
she's all babies listen to four gay men
those are women
those are not women i just realized this
is the worst episode of the view ever
we will give you love advice we'll let
you know what's going on with your mans
and you're blind
one on there yeah that's you this the
fighter and the talk
this is i don't know the i forget don't
they switch them out
oh no you don't it's like it's like
there's a redhead then there's uh
barbara they got barber on there
barbara walters i think she is no
she's raving someone who's the one in
the middle that's all that [ __ ]
who no that's not that middle that's not
batman
so sharon osbourne is not on the view
anymore i think they switch them out
right they switch them and they rotate
them differently there's another one
whoopi's been there
rosie bro oh [ __ ] you got these
you couldn't look any more like whoopi
goldberg right i told her i told him
that
you yeah hey pull up the paper at least
like her wait do you serve your
sunglasses
your glasses oh yeah put them on
chappelle but they don't they don't
oh but we need smaller ones yeah if you
rest them on the
on the bridge of your nose yeah wrestle
on the bridge your nose like you get
like you like you're reading a recipe
all this [ __ ]
how do you guys do it you need glasses
anyway so it's good for you no now put
them down a little bit
no there it is
uh welcome back to the you definitely
you definitely do look like the coach of
the knicks in nineteen what was that
movie when she was the cause
eddie yeah oh yeah i'll take it
i [ __ ] with whoopi bro you remember
malcolm and eddie you can't look like
old boy
jamal warner not the other one but the
dress malcolm jerome warner okay cool
i have one more and we're good at you
all right hey what do we say about this
last dude
we just said we're just telling you oh
yeah yeah
don't bring your pass into the new
relationship man take it from the team
here
yeah i love doctor i'm 32 and single i'm
on tinder and seem to do well and meet a
decent amount of women
problem is i've never seen to meet
someone i'd want a relationship with i
think i'm so used to being
in my own routine having my own freedom
that i never picture any of these women
to be my queen to change that
am i being selfish and should i change
or should i wait for the right woman to
come along thanks for your help dane i
love you bro
no keep those standards high dog okay
why you say that because man you don't
want to just say yes to anything
[ __ ] gets [ __ ] but relationships about
compromise compromise no
i'm what do you mean what are you
compromised but maybe but he's on tinder
we're really [ __ ]
tender he's oh no he's not
he says tinder and other things he
didn't he just he didn't say that
anything is he on pharmacists
yeah well here's the thing he's on
jayday he's a little jade
mainly black he wants a relationship
mainly
[ __ ] you know farmers no farmers
you know you know farmersonly.com
really well you don't you don't have
like there's blacks
like black.com there's farmers only.com
yeah
but there's also a dating site black
something but farmers only
see white people only what
like when you think about it is
basically
it's just saying white people only but
they can't say whites only because
they're farmers
they say farmers only yeah but whites
only but
black people like farmers i was about
but listen it's white
it's white people in black.com by the
way this this set looks like a diner
that none of us would be allowed out of
the 50s
ain't nobody giving us 50.
you got any negro pie hi can i get a
milkshake
you say about 35 miles down oh did you
have biscuits and gravy
this guy this guy should keep his uh
standards uh where they're at man you
you want the good one man
man and fight for it man it may take a
little longer
but you know what man like yeah you
gotta crack a few omelettes or crack a
few eggs like an omelette
what did you say yeah
get glasses yeah yeah you're trying to
get weird you gotta try a few wigs
before your game
no one's ever heard that no i'll say you
should be so
um don't be selfish man like i
understand copper compromise that's what
i said
he said he wants a relationship well
you're on tinder first of all get off
tinder yeah i agree
okay he said he feel like he wants to be
in a relationship that
with the woman he never met his words
not mine go to church that is true
yeah no yeah church i guess but also
you can't really go to church right now
miss watkins what do you say
miss watkins you go to home what do you
think yeah you go to whole
foods they got a lot of business a lot
of girls he'll go to a park go to target
rent a puppy dude target come on let's
not get into it there dude target
there's oh
say it again
targets popping from the staff to the
people in there yeah
right jeremiah has no clue what the [ __ ]
is going on i've been to a target in a
minute i guess
are you saying i'm there weekly man give
me something out there a week
okay okay what's the rating system
between girls who work at target
costco and ralph
[Music]
you did it perfect okay target is creme
de la creme and you go all the way down
it goes all the way down then round okay
matt's got some dragons
what about trader joe's try to they
don't have too many women as
like working in there there's a lot of
news on hawaiian shirts yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oliver hawaiian shirt
i think you stroll around whole foods
though whole foods is where is that but
it's not people that's working there
it's like
it's the parts of the patrons yeah hang
out the produce correct now you want to
see some bad
um h m really you got to go to h m at
the group really yes that one they're
working
[ __ ] up right because they only have
the limited capacity
what do you mean the the work is the
staff they're bad but limited capacity
so it's like
so what three baggage yeah you're right
all right okay glad we saw that out hey
thank you
h m yeah h m's limited capacity yeah
yeah and target's not
no target should be booming
which one are we talking about
i think you can't change a routine too
if you have your set routines i agree
that there's
compromise and relationships and stuff
like that yeah but like if you
are set in your ways too much like you
have your certain things that you like
you probably should find a person that
also likes those things rather than
shifting everything oh that's what you
were trying to say basically
i get that i miss translating i know
right about
things i want to articulate because all
you got to say was compromise i was like
well i couldn't get a word
you want to want them to compromise with
trash i couldn't get a word out not
saying all you women are trash on tinder
but i'm just saying
i don't
[Applause]
if you start saying child i want to die
but is tinder any different than like
instagram dm instagram
same [ __ ] social media platforms just
better women
but well well i think instagram dms are
different because
they like to put up on this front but
tinder i heard again
you never been on tinder no never been
unattended but i got a friend no yeah he
never
i never but look i have a friend and we
all know him i ain't gonna say his name
it rhymes with justin and he's gonna
tinder and he hook in each city dm them
and guaranteeing on that night he had
you know have sex with him but i'm
saying if
that's what i'm saying because the dm on
instagram they like to put up his front
like take me out on a date like
remember that big chick in utah the real
big one the big one she had an attitude
because he was on a date with her and
stuff like that he was like look girl i
don't need this
and then tinder he was like i could have
hit that you know but in the way but
it's a front though
all i'm saying what's the front the the
instagram dms he's like what's the
difference
i was like he's all the time i'm out of
the game i don't know yeah but i'm
saying like they like the front on dms
cat i need a woman's opinion is that
true no i think tinder is
mostly like you're trying to hook up and
[ __ ] whereas
in dm's you're just dming some random
girl you don't know if she's down to
[ __ ] maybe she just wants to meet a nice
guy
i don't think it's necessarily a front
what malek is trying to say
tinder is straight to the point okay and
dm's there's all these games that are
being played all these facades that are
going on and stuff like that
and it's like do we want to hook up
are we a thing what's happening between
us where tinder is like let's go
straight to the goods
yes you look like the girl from call her
daddy right now
this is a nightmare caller daddy episode
hey [ __ ] i sucked this dick last
night it was crazy and
do i look like i turned it for real no
you don't look like i turned cause he
had hair like this he did a little bit
yeah but i mean that's a good job
if jeremiah was a chick if we met him or
we met her we'd go in the backpack
she kind of hopped her nose
like straight on that [ __ ] looks good
but she turned to the left
i was like what the hell
that's so drastic she looks like a
barbie
she looks like a barbie straight on she
looks like a minion when she turns
despicable me over here
[ __ ] that's where i gain weight it goes
out of my nose
that [ __ ] fix her nose she's back
oh my god i'm trying to put shading
yo you stupid dog cause that's a real
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh
hey i know we
just hypothetically right
because we're some [ __ ] right hey
y'all guys
so let's just say i was talking to
jeremiah like that wait wait wait wait
wait let's take this out i'm going to be
turning around
hey hold on hold on this is hey what's
up hey hey
i think they won't call me a little bit
hey uh chappelle
chappelle you mean yeah i call you like
that no man
you need
hello he's doing improv in the 60s over
here
hey bro you ever have your homies just
like talking to a girl and your homies
just come up and just send subliminal
shots like hey bro you good
like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly we
just tease him y'all tease me hey man
your girl look like she knows what she's
doing
she knows what you're doing jason
we all about to go who knows
does anybody want a drink yes or no
i called chappelle he go chickalette man
is that a good burger ring [ __ ] no
you just you said call you
i was following your lead brother don't
be too much in this diner though he's
not chilling with me
sound like a registered all right all
right let's go to colonel vance
oh [ __ ] i lost my wig oh [ __ ]
i tell you this that's just so funny
about the wigs
because i thought this was gonna last
for like five minutes
oh my god here you go
[ __ ] grow up
oh okay hey kids if you
sell stuff online you know how busy 2020
was
everyone and their mama was shopping
online rightfully so nobody trying to go
into the shops
nobody wants to wear a mask all the time
so you're doing it from your crib well
let's get ready for 21.
it's going to be even bigger that's why
online sellers like you
ship station you need ship station no
matter how much you sell
ship station makes it super easy to
manage and ship all your orders
from all your sales channels faster
cheaper
more efficiently all right ship with any
care using
their deeply discounted rates automate
just about
any shipping task you want with
shipstation you'll spend a lot less time
on shipping
and a lot more time on growing your
freaking business it's no wonder
ship station has more five star reviews
than any other
shipping software out there no matter
what you're selling where you're selling
amazon etsy your own website shipstation
brings you
all your orders in one simple interface
making them really easy to manage from
any device even your cell phone
shipstation works with all the major
carriers including usps
fedex ups so you can compare and choose
the best shipping solution
for you and your customers ship station
ship station even offers big discounts
on shipping rates
now any business can access the same
discounts usually reserved for large
fortune 500 companies but not at ship
station you always know that you're
getting the best deal
period there's a good reason shipstation
is the number one choice of online
sellers get 2021
off to a great start by visiting
shipstation.com
just use the offer code fighter to get a
60 day free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress free shipping
just go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone top of the home page
type in fighter that's shipstation.com
enter off code fighter
ship station make ship happen hey man
there's nobody on the planet like you so
why would you buy a generic mattress
built for
everybody else you thick or you're a
stick boy
thick boy whatever you are helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete
and it matches you with the perfect
mattress built for your thick ass body
with your side sleeper hot sleeper
plush firm with helix there's no more
confusion
alright helix sleep was even awarded
number one best overall mattress pick of
2019 2020 by gq and wired magazine
i got him at my crib my mother-in-law
freaking father-in-law brother-in-law
everybody trying to stay at my crib
they get the best night's sleep ever
thanks to helix sleep.com
fighter alright so go there to
helixleep.com
fighter take their two minute sleep quiz
and they will match you
with a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your thick
ass life they have a 10 year warranty
you get to try out for 100 nights risk
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you well so don't
worry about that
helix sleep is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and free pillows for
you guys
at helix sleep.com fighter that's helix
sleep.com
fighter for up to two hundred dollars
off oh
okay so this was submitted by evan wags
pack on instagram
two gorillas in the san diego zoo tested
positive for covid19 and they're
currently assuming that the rest of the
uh gorillas in the exhibit also have oh
no they're not going to be able to taste
their leaves for a few weeks
i mean okay they're already [ __ ]
quarantined
they keep going that is true
they're saying that the staff member who
feeds and takes care of the girls
ended up having covet 19 and he he
spread it to the rest of their staff
this is our revenge
[Laughter]
during uh coconutty press briefing gavin
has said two gorillas have tested
[ __ ] off oh newsome said it
he's just full of bad news it was like
if covet isn't bad
yeah you guys know timmy and fluff
laughter
as well pretty much
so this door dash driver uh was angry
about her tip she says
that she drove 40 minutes for food for
the person who ordered it and dropped it
off and she was unhappy about the eight
dollar tip that she was given
but it's weird because the place that
she said she got the food from
and where she had to drop it off on
google maps is only
a five to six mile drive depending on
what route you take and it should take
anywhere between 15 to 20 minutes to get
to and from yeah postmates and doordash
if you like if i
let's say you know i live i don't know
yes within a certain district if i live
18 miles from let's say prince pizza or
uh bootleg pizza and i try to order it
it's going to say out of range
yeah oh yeah yeah but there is this
video
that came on uh their ring that their
ring camera and it wasn't posted until i
believe it was
yesterday but this happened in august
they snitched 30 minutes and it was
extremely fun
[Music]
oh she said again
here i don't think you realize where
they're coming from so i need to speak
to you
oh wow where was coming from
where the food you ordered it's coming
from i don't think you realize
the distance that it comes from because
then you would never
actually had given what you've given
this lady is a hundred percent the wrong
yeah you can come and see face to face
because i drew 40 minutes i drove 40
minutes
and it was extremely far and i got it
too early what's on you dumbass
i don't think
no this is crazy yeah that's insane
um he should just keep going i don't
understand
just mess with it yeah yeah did you hear
this
do you realize you ordered from tarmac
and you're in smithtown
that's a that's a 15-20 minute drive
it's not
you need to try to drive it i just drove
it it's 40 minutes
it's it's 12 and a half miles
so i don't think you realize how far it
is but i think you could have to pick up
if you think it's that far i don't
remember how far
what the hell are you looking forward
apparently doordash didn't actually know
about this incident until this video
went
by so i don't know if the customer
actually reported it to doordash or not
but they decided to post this footage
the other day
there are a few things wrong with our
story one uh you
as a door dash driver get to choose
which
orders you pick up based off of distance
so they tell you where you're gonna go
and how far it is
before you actually accept the ride so
that's a lie and then it clearly does
not take
40 minutes to get there unless there's
heavy traffic but even then she said
it was 12 miles away yeah it's not she
met about
eight dollars too yeah eight dollar tip
like what was the bill eight dollars
pretty good
eslay is just in the wrong god
you gotta you gotta [ __ ] tip it man
yeah yeah yeah
all right take care of essential workers
guys um okay
so a there is a device that you can buy
off of amazon that'll have an
app where you it's basically a chastity
bill you put your dick in it and you can
lock it
and through the app you can open it or
keep it locked
so this is i guess really popular in the
bdsm community
and so there are people who want to have
their dick locked you can't
so you can't get hard you can't pee out
of it it's also
water resistant why would you do this
it's some people's kink brendan
wait what's bdsm uh so what does it
stand for uh
bond bondage uh
silent d is dominatrix i think
bondage discipline submission and
okay so that a part of that community
so apparently it's a pretty
good popular app for that community and
what ended up happening was
their server got hacked and the hacker
kept a bunch of people's dicks locked
and held hostage until they paid that
person in bitcoin
and at the time when they were sending
out these random messages
bitcoin uh the amount that they were
asking for was valued at seven hundred
fifty dollars
it's not terrible not terrible but at
the same time they can't pee out of it
either
you can pee in it but you're gonna have
piss everywhere because water resistant
you still can't get your dick out of it
oh
that's what we're gonna have to do are
you here you would keep it on i'd pee
dude really are you serious i'd be hard
dude i would fry the system man
i wouldn't hold this but but how does it
come off cat i don't get it it's locked
so there's a dick
i don't know exactly how it works from
the photos but
it's supposed to lock your dick into
place i wonder if we could google an
image of like
oh okay so you see that place at the
bottom your balls go down there
yeah and then the penis goes on the
front and then the front is like a hatch
that won't fit for mine that's what i'm
gonna say it's gonna be a touch they
probably have different sizes
oh okay yeah and then but then how does
it stay on and all that yeah
i i don't it's gotta be a belt but all
he asked for was 750 bucks
from uh well he asked for i believe it
was .02
bitcoin which valued at 750.
like dude and so the person who sent out
that message their username on the
platform was
smelly and they sent the message your
car your [ __ ] is mine now to the victims
your [ __ ] is mine now yeah that's
terrifying but also
if you're into that that might be great
i don't know
it's got music to it have you ever
wanted to lock your penis
we've got the solution for you over here
at cellmate
he said are you man enough oh definitely
you have different sizes
okay but what if this thing didn't fit
oh boy
a ring that best fits you so it goes
around your nuts and you're nuts man
wow it's like a vice it's harder to get
off awesome it must be so
uncomfortable dude that's terrifying
tell you what ladies when we keep a man
from cheating
put that damn thing on lock it up yeah
nah they'll still find a way yeah
how no over that thing oh my goodness
let's get this
sweater oh now it started soaking
yeah so it's wrapped around your balls
it looks like there is a pee hole yeah
on that one
on that one on the one you showed there
was it yeah it didn't look like there
was a pee hole in there
it's pretty sweet this one looks like a
physical chastity belt the other one
looks like it's more electronic
i didn't know these things existed same
thing
that's rough but yeah some people have
their decks locked up currently
cause i'm locked up
won't let me out locked up won't let me
out no
don't let me out it's beautiful i love
it anytime we could drop an eight kind
like
boris in here i'm all for it wow
next one yeah all right it's over
wait wait but would you guys wear one oh
yeah
so like if i was wearing one right now
would you judge me
like are they do you guys not like them
like what's the problem
i got bitcoin right but have you ever
worn
different color different tastes have
you seen this picture
this is at the when they stormed the
capitol chuck norris yeah everyone
thought i was shocking horse because
look how much he looks like
i met chuck norris that is walking
that's not him yeah we're not just going
to mention the fact that chuck norris is
at the
uh that's just people he looks a lot
like him though he looks like he looks
like chuck norris if he broke his
[ __ ] nose
and then chuck norris responded with
this picture yeah no yeah i would say
learning the word
look alike at the dc cavalry it wasn't
me and i wasn't there there's no room
for violence of any kind in our society
i am always will be for law and order
your friend chuck
what uh
the damn thing like he's so short he has
to be is he small
yeah he's short he just be 75 yeah he's
in the 70s he's still trucking right
yeah there was something where uh some
someone tried to attack him he beat
their ass
he was on a run [ __ ] he's he's 80. damn
he doesn't
want him i wonder how his kicks are and
stuff like that still
he's got to still train a little bit
right i can't be no i'm saying i'm
telling you
it was something he got in a fight or
someone tried to attack him while he was
running
you know he beat their ass he knows uh
brazilian jiu jitsu
chuck norris defends himself on a run or
something i'll just say like training
today or recent
six years ago no they're still older
he's not posting anything well there you
go
he's on tick tock just taking people
he's he's a real deal
hi you faff students i heard from your
instructors
that you've been doing a great job with
your online classes
hold on somebody
i love chuck norris though i do i used
to watch walker texas right now every
day
bro right before school i loved it right
before school now
the eyes of a ranger are upon you yep no
one else i know
so ufc hall of famer pat meltic he works
for lfa
legacy fighting alliance or something
like that and he was fired because he
was
i guess not really doing anything at the
protest but he was there just because he
was there he was there yeah it's a weird
this one it's a like now if he was in
the capitol and trying to break
that yeah yeah you probably gotta fire
him it's weird to fire a guy just
because peaceful protesting democratic
yeah
it's weird yeah cause guy to lose his
job because he doesn't
believe in your same political opinion
regardless of what you believe you have
the right to protest yeah that's weird
well protest peace peace it's peaceful
yeah yeah
which was it was weird because he didn't
he didn't raid the capital
anything he said i saw zero violence she
got a call from the folks at lfa they
informed me that they were getting a lot
of pressure because i was at the capitol
this is part of the problem when people
put pressure on these businesses in
these big industries
and they they succumb to the pressure if
they're like hold up
listen no matter your republican
democrat he was out there but he wasn't
he wasn't part of the problem he's just
out there
we can't fight and i'm sure he has a
case legally
if he wanted to sue them i would think
so you can't fire someone over
their belief system or their political
views or whatever but where does it stop
oh well he's muslim so we're going to
fire him because we're christian here
like what the [ __ ]
it's weird man just going down a weird
weird road and it's not that i agree
with the
protest or any of that but i i don't not
like
you know pat milicic because he's at the
protest
he's still a good guy if you know pat
he's a [ __ ] great guy
peaceful protest you shouldn't be fired
yeah peaceful no matter what yeah no
matter what
now if he was at like a [ __ ] kkk
rally that's different
it's a little different but that's
inciting violence though yeah correct
so like that's but that's what pat said
he's like dude i was there i wasn't part
of the [ __ ] violence
that was you know yeah we're going down
a dangerous road whether you agree with
it or not you just can't fire someone
because they're not
democratic or they don't believe in what
you believe in yeah agree
all right this is a nascar driver female
nascar driver
have you seen it before haley deegan
uses r word
r word you know the r word mentally yeah
oh that didn't even enter my me neither
brain i didn't even think
i did it but i'm playing stupid i really
are
this has been happening quite a bit too
when people do these like um cyber races
virtual races against their teammates
because you know it's video games yeah
when they're streaming
accidentally here's the problem with
this
is how old is she she's young 20
something the sh
i don't think she really means 19
mentally disabled
it's a term like when i was a term
obviously not cool now i'm a lot older
now
when i was a kid or you go on youtube
comments now like get oh that's gay
that's get you know we're not calling
you a homosexual it's just like a term
so like even me growing up be like dude
don't be [ __ ] you're not saying
don't be mentally handicapped it's just
like a it's like uh
the word it's in the vernacular like
it's just the way people talk
it has a life for themselves the [ __ ] is
that on the right though yeah
no nfl wild card i didn't see that yeah
keep going keep going you want to watch
yeah i'll watch it let me see let me see
you drop this one yeah i'll watch it
this is fun oh hey who's behind me don't
do that please
that was it this is fun so she has take
what sensitivity classes or something
like that
yeah sensitivity training again well i'm
from in the south and even in the hip
hop songs look like bro my diamond's
going stupid
you know that r word so they mean it in
a good way so it's just kind of like
what do you
do you remember the original black eyed
peas version let's see yeah let's get
right
in here yeah yeah
all right he starts drooling like
brendan
easy dude but yeah with her i don't
think she really meant to offend
mentally disabled people it's
it's like uh you know i get it man so
i just realized that's so you know brian
deegan he was like a bmx
kind of a freestyle biker is that who's
harder he has well he commits suicide
too because of ctv
oh yeah yeah and that's his daughter
that's his daughter
it says brian deegan i don't think
there's many other brian deegan's yeah
you're right
yeah yeah yeah that's him that poor girl
i just watched her
wait wait i messed up she's not going no
no no no no no that's not the guy that
died that's not the guy
it was dave uh mira mir yeah i'm sorry
my bad my bad
way off way off well two bmxers well
yeah you guys are really
watch the uh matt hoffman documentary if
you haven't yet that's pretty good that
often
yeah i'll check that out yeah you will
no i was like i think it's more for
chappelle yeah i know right now yeah
yeah yeah
yeah but she's not getting cancelled
right no no she just has to go through
that training classes
here's the thing you could look at it on
either side when you're representing
those like huge major brands honestly
the fact that she
like that they're just doing that for
her that's better than just being like
oh we're releasing it from our brand
she's going to take a class or two
like like she just needs to but it's
hard because like that uh
online like gaming and streaming like
people talk
trash kind of like that's right
because you know you can listen and you
have your heads and they know they know
you're black
yeah well they're just using it in
general i think that they're just using
it to try to be edgy
like with their friends or whatever so
when you can kill when you kill someone
you can just like say
like little like when you have like take
that [ __ ] a little
trash talk there's like mother you know
and i just got an xbox shout out to my
sponsors
and they just like literally they're
killing me but oh my god you know
it's like it's like rollyboy8259 we find
out his sponsor is this his alcohol
sponsor
for not drinking as much yeah
now jeremiah that's [ __ ] up again i
like that that's great but do those kids
they're not
the n word to them doesn't mean the same
that it does to like the older
generation
because they hear it in every rap song
right so to them it's no it's the er
brittany
it's oh oh it's trash
like you hear a lot of different races
though like
i don't want to get canceled but it's
like cb cave
boom to like disrespect white people
what
a cave baby i don't know that is oh you
don't know what that is
no doesn't disrespect white people yeah
okay baby call me a cave baby yeah they
call you okay
why i think they gotta i think they
gotta go back to the drawing board
like a caveman extremely ugly girl
that is disgusting you don't even want
to go near no hey dude your sister's
friend is a kid
baby not that no that's awesome
that's awesome i'm going to start using
it
justin showed me a picture of this girl
like oh that's a caveman
leave that [ __ ] in the cage dude
baby she's sick okay all right you're
scribing ugly girls
are you sure it's cb are you usually not
talking like calling other girls ugly no
because i'm white i've never heard that
term oh i heard crack or even that you
get even hotties
you gotta come up with better than
crackers young kids don't even use that
anymore i'm trying to say that
baby hey baby uh
i don't know it's just like more of like
the n words though like even like white
people call
other white people inwards on that game
like yeah yeah yeah someone called me
the n word i'd find that more offensive
and they call me cracker like
because right guys like you [ __ ]
white boy or something like that like i
mean you're you know like other stuff
but the the whites they like me inward
and i'm like oh that's what the plus
that you get banned from that
like like you can message each other off
the line and if i see your screen name
like you like brandon327 i just see your
private message like yo you
mother and we just talk [ __ ] and then
what are you weird
yeah what a toxic world it's fun though
it's like this one's
a game that sounds good it's good game
yeah i'll only go on there and play
video you can be called the n
world well no it's
that's not the object of the game that's
just part of it
you're making it about that yeah you're
making it about that it's so fun the
other day
i couldn't i couldn't handle it i don't
need that toxic world yeah
other people where you're just here like
i would just be hearing each other and
we're like oh like these are not going
to call you the n-word
right and then i'll be like whatever
cave because
is a great name for an ugly chick what i
didn't know that was the definition
wow yeah cave baby cave baby yeah i
thought that was great
cave girl man all right cave girl
dude did we just start something yeah we
did cave girl how's that cave girl
you guys basically call me a butter nose
earlier
she can't change it brendan it's so real
because there's always one
how about that nose though i mean she
got body though yeah she got body
[Laughter]
has joined the ranks of fighting or
boxing celebrity boxing no he didn't
yeah for the summer i hate how they go
i know that's like a thing
that's that world star hip-hop
who was like hey man let's do this
announcement let me take a picture
hey put your hands on let's take a
picture with this
looks sick and he looks like he looks
terrified right now
you don't want to do this lamar he got
to get he looked punched drunk already
how does he not have enough money not to
do this yeah he don't need to do this
why
yeah why is he doing this being a
celebrity box in my food truck direct
tyson drops tomorrow shout out
shout out oh heck yeah but man i don't
get this celebrity but
for one he's not a celebrity i want to
see fight
yeah i don't know but listen no more
hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on let your
boy here okay
you're telling me you don't want to see
jake paul knock lamar odom out
you know what nothing they're not going
to put it against him
because he's already knocked out nate
robinson exactly so they're not going to
put him against
i bet you lamar owns better boxer nate
robinson right now did you see
dan's hands okay what are you talking
about
i'm not going to [ __ ] up yeah
why are you doing that
yeah he makes that sound effect when he
boxes
wow now remember though he died and came
back to life
he's done crack yeah he's done a bunch
of [ __ ] and yeah dude i hope they
announce him like that
you know you know him from the bunny
ranch he's
come back to life three times
the more the undertaker the undertaker
that's how they try to put it yeah he
wants to travel
he can't remember when he went rogue at
the bunny ranch he died
kim kard uh khloe kardashian it was a
bunny ranch
butter it's really bad he literally know
so it's in reno
it's uh legal prostitution and they used
to have a show on chat
i think the guy passed away but the
bunny ranch is the legal prostitution
so you go there and you can pick out the
girls that's what they look like
[ __ ] some of you there's some super bad
ones there's some super bad brothers one
black i'm talking about
it was one oh no there's some super
baddies there but it's not cheap
but check it out cheap bro this is like
how to knock these women
them some cave babies but listen
yeah but so lamar odom went there when
when he was go like on
[ __ ] when he went rogue he went there
and just stayed for like four days
in the vip room it cost him i don't know
like 200 grand and she had girls girls
girls
drugs drugs drugs and then that's when
they flew in and had to [ __ ] bring
him back so
go to that picture with lamar and those
two girls these right
is that the girls that he was getting
with yeah there's some cave babies
brain dead after 75k brothel binge
yeah and now he's fighting in the ring
now they have better looking women yeah
they they don't do them like that yeah
don't do them like that don't
don't show us those cave babies they're
they're some real [ __ ]
that's a normal word because we just
looked up urban dictionary all right so
hopefully there's nothing yeah urban
dictionary is legit though okay
all right i thought i don't want to say
it that's the funniest thing i've ever
heard
we find out after this episode it's like
something crazy that's
crazy well we're going we're going off
we fact checked we went to urban
we're going off tonight we're going for
urban dictionary let's go to another one
because i think that's like disrespect
because i was like bro
what do you mean yeah but if they if
they call you a cave baby they call me
that they're
yeah they did if they called you that on
there that means you're just an
ugly person yeah it just sounds like
yeah it just means
sounds like all okay ugly all right
anyways go to a better picture of this
bunny ranch
listen those are from the those are like
early 2000s i know bro you got to chill
you got all sorts of celebrities in
there
but they closed it down [ __ ] no that
place is a business just because of god
vegas prostitution is legal
yeah yeah they'd be booming out there
go to the bunny ranch website because i
bet you can pick out the women that you
want to book
no that makes sense oh yeah that's the
name of it is cat house yep that's the
bunny ranch no but the name of the hbo
series
oh it was fantastic bro i used to watch
it late at night
like jet jamie remember that [ __ ] jamie
jamie dwight girl i see a bunny ash bar
and restaurant
yeah that's probably it i think i don't
think so broder no they're
all right they probably they're serving
burgers at that place bro
ducey's going there he used to show like
three i'm getting three there it is
now she's gonna show some of the girls
baddies
girls girls girls girls girls
gay bunnies that's the bunny of these
top bunny okay
alice little she's probably pretty tiny
but she probably freaky
okay i like t i like oh you don't like
tara taylor
where's it say tara tay on the side oh
air force amy she's been there for
30 years my air force actually reached
us
i'll suck your dick for a quarter back
in my day
is that a susan b what's up dog damn 27.
everybody all right
34 double d son
hold on hold on go to uh i want to see
rosie you talking about tessa rose sir i
want to see rose
let me just see that real quick because
i want to see what that tattoo looks
like and i'm going to be off of it is
there any other picks
just the one that's that one oh go to
the sex menu we don't see what
who's gone oh there is a sex man yeah
what you get advertising
for how much this is bizarre yeah this
is crazy so champagne bj
who would do this you're right this is
so fair you're right i see where you're
going but this is feels good
look at the main course main course
what's the main course say
girls who provide bisexual encounters
oh that means she's uh she'll do a
three-way
oh gotcha got your sexual adventures
okay this is what you did now they don't
give pricing
no well hold on uh i wonder if they have
a secret menu like in and out like
different stuff like that hey can i get
the number i'll take air force amy
that's an animal style
did you drag it through the garden
no special order number two fetishes uh
yeah where are the pricing at uh
girls can suck you off you see that line
right there look right here
where did you say that females hands and
your toes can
suck to your hearts they'll oh sucks
that's a second time
whipped cream chocolate sauce even baked
beans
who wants baked beans hey air force amy
guy wants baked beans
i just [ __ ] ate i know he won he
wants honey baked beans
i just used my teeth to open this cake
now you know like right on there you
don't have to eat a ton of it but just
play with it all right what a [ __ ]
job i just ate jeffrey bro air force amy
is a oh geez
yeah she's the original og yeah [ __ ] she
was on the tv show she was
yeah she was like main star really yeah
she was like 30 she was like 20 like 30
yeah she had a real high pitched voice
was it like a reality show yeah it was
fantastic like that bro
and gigolo's on show time bro i love
gigolos
talk to me bro you know you know the
bald guy he's like next
the bit with the tattoos that little
tattoo on him no he murdered somebody
what the [ __ ] when he's in prison for
murder are you serious yeah the one with
the longest
and he had like bro he uh he was [ __ ]
that girl in the bed
yeah the bald guy though i
saw him when the show was popping i saw
him off venice
you'd have thought leonardo dicaprio i
went oh
[ __ ] i was like dawg he was like whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh [ __ ] yeah cause it's private yeah he
killed a lady
mr dude bro beat her to death are you
serious that boy was
bodied uh bro let me tell you that hair
yo
he used to smack on these women oh dude
he would lay it down
bro he's my favorite so gigolo did they
show it right let me tell you that call
you up they show them having sex bro yes
fantastic it's on demand now yeah oh
that's the guy i saw the second one
yeah dude you see the guy with the hat i
hated the guy in the white hair i hated
the guy
oh bryce yeah oh he's the original man
hey the guy in the hat though you think
can you rap better than him go to his uh
youtube for me what was that can you
write about
him he's a rapper okay of course i don't
know why we're doing this right right
y'all are balls deep in this
i know bro so look let me just say what
they do they'll call you
up right gigolo women with like lonely
women right and then they're sick
they'll come over these dudes looking
like that
they'll have a little bit of words and
they'll get straight to [ __ ] dude
remember the one girl made a bunch of
glory holes
his name's nick [ __ ] she made a bunch of
glory holes there he is
god damn look at that goddamn i don't
remember that any of you guys have any
action last couple days
i had a client what's one of the best
shows of all time yeah
you said nick hawk bro are you tripping
this can't be that nick guy also
competed at purple belt in
like serious jitsu this can't be a great
show
oh no no you're not it's not great i'm
saying it's
fantastic dude i fast forward it's so
entertaining now can you write better
name go to the
the official music than him
real quick yeah let's see if rolly boy
is better than our boy nick hawk
let me see we fight bro oh
director director nick producer nick
hawk
he had the venom tattoo is he in the
comments
dude he used to [ __ ] sounds like some
[Music]
eminem
yeah but crazy town was good oh i don't
i can take a punch go that way
i can take it you're my butterfly
baby
[Music]
no no jeremiah have an open opinion
right you hit it it's
so bad the good musician and chin right
now is just
so hard no wait wait no we're gonna have
a judge contest let's see
go to rolly boy little sean this on
youtube and you be the judge
and just fast forward his best one's
called wrecking ball hasn't
stopped a thousand this is not even my
best song though
how many views is your hand no no worry
about the top one yeah topping right
there all right
how many viewers got 327 bro 27 yeah
342.
just fast forward a little bit so
jeremiah can hear a little bit
right now
[Music]
big sean man [ __ ] big shot rolly boy
[Music]
it's all a hot mess isn't it it's pretty
rough
because like your wrapping style is like
big sean
what's going on i think something's not
right it's wrong
you're flowing down the street with this
beat with his hat on the cat and the rat
tat tap
are you trying to battle right now okay
you want to go
that's like preschool rats over here big
sean big shot
big chunk i was writing luck big shot
big shots
back to your guy hey why did you say he
was tight i was about to say at least
like entertaining yeah he's entertaining
he's so entertaining but also
his music video has 350 000 views that
was the positive that was that was a
time when gigolos was popping
if he comes out right now i guarantee
that was three years ago so
if you put out a track right now do you
think it would pop off
well bro i got
yeah nick hawk does have more views than
you yeah yeah but that was the time when
gigolos was popping
when did this show come out in 2013 yeah
but
so that video was three years ago so
that came out in 2018 the one that has
350 000 views
let me see go to go to what's name nick
355. click on it let's just feel it oh
wow see
[Music]
but my production is way better i have a
video
directed by chris angel
all his videos are the same
oh my god so these women just hit these
things up
he's lost yeah i just put out a music
video got like 7
000 views so it did okay you put on a
music video i put out music videos
[ __ ] chin let me type in halitosis you
know
what that's a catchy name yeah [ __ ] this
guess your name
halitosis jeremiah watkins oh snap
what is that it was a year ago seven no
no we just put this out
what is january 5th catalina
[Music]
yeah a bunch
[Music]
[Music]
montgomery uh huh
[Music]
[Music]
oh you got kevin mac in here being a
supermodel uh-huh
i didn't know
my buddy raniere pollard and the amount
of guys that got upset because they
thought it was a girl at first was
so funny clue me i mean malik was like
who is that
because you don't see a black only black
girl you see is the main one and then
i didn't see a black dude in like pink
shorts and i'm like god damn
who's the girl in pink though the real
girl uh her name is angela she
she's a comic uh no met her through uh
mutual chin she's an angel you wanted to
see it didn't she
is
all right well you definitely have the
best music that we've
mm-hmm i'll take it i'll
oh crap yeah you guys want to do uh shoe
cam
no no arm the arny hammer story that she
had arm in half
arm and hammer army hammer you know what
i'm talking about he was in uh
social justice he had to run movies
yeah bunch of movies social networks
by your name what one ranger was
huh lone ranger was he in that too i
don't know i think he
i think he was yeah yeah what happened
to him okay his dm's got like they're so
intense
it's about him saying that he is 100 a
cannibal
yeah he's a cannibal like he says that
he is
into cannibalism he's also into a
very very violent form of bdsm like he
wants to
he said that he's wanted to cut women's
toes off and keep it with him
he wants to [ __ ] their literal brains uh
he likes rape fantasies do we know if
this is real or not i don't know
here's the thing a lot of people when it
came out a few days ago
said it was fake and it's super easy to
fake dm's which it is
but what's interesting after that is
that his ex-wife came out and said that
she actually
believes these dm's are real hi two of
his ex-girlfriends also came out and
said similar things
people are enter into that like stuff
though and the weird thing is like this
has blown up so much over social media
to the point where he was trending
and he hasn't come out to say that it
wasn't real he just said that there were
a lot of girls who have been dming him
offering themselves for these things so
he never said
it's not true he never and if you go
through his social media before all of
this there's a lot of really weird
photos of him cooking like the way with
like bloody meat and everything now that
you know all these things weird easter
eggs
yeah he also he comes from like super
like
super rich family she grew up super
entitled so
at certain points there is one thing
that is a little funny about all of this
in one of the dms with someone he said
you are like the michael phelps of
[ __ ]
everyone else just doesn't have what you
have to a girl
that's the only thing that's remotely
funny but
michael phelps a [ __ ] no because
everything else is super [ __ ]
dark dark like i want to cut you into
pieces and i
uh this is my last resort sorry i
have a bunch of screenshots from the
account that was blasting all this
because the girl who came out
she says that she's had a sexual
relationship with him for four years
oh he looks insane you want to play he
says stuff like
that it's just i just saw a pop-up right
now on the news
real quick you've been taking drugs
while driving it's just him thinking
but here's the thing that you know i i
don't know how it's gonna affect his
acting sure but
if these girls are down for it obviously
not
foods like they're into it he's into it
it's not breaking
cannibalism is illegal though yeah yeah
but he but i'm saying
it might be a fantasy like somebody's
watching a short handoff but he's not
really doing that well we don't know
that
what is that do we do we know if any
girl's hand is eating off that's the
thing we don't either on both sides we
don't know if this is real or not
more one more yo he just took drugs off
a dude's hand
why would he film this like he's acting
[Music]
drinking drinking and driving
[Music]
there was also a that's not there's also
an article
back from 2013 on hollywood.com talking
about how he was doing
a short film about people cutting
themselves
so him and a friend were doing like some
sort of documentary about
people and it's a lot of footage of them
cutting themselves and him recording it
but
he came out and says that he had no
plans to officially release it
and that was back in 2013 he's a freak
people uh very like born into wealth
they like
you know today they yeah isn't that
weird is they bored
like joshua's got everything yeah you
remember ready or not remember that
movie where there is uh
that wealthy family like will hunt the
new girlfriend
in a wedding dress but that really
happens and stuff like that yeah i don't
know if that
really happens but um oh here's one that
keeps going viral he says i want to
brand you
tattoo you mark you shave your head and
keep your hair with me
cut a piece of your skin off and make
you cook it for me i mean i feel the
tests can be endless
who's the slave master relationship is
the strongest we'd win
he's a freak yeah and that's the thing
we don't know if it's real or not these
are just things that have been put out
here it could be a really good promo for
a new movie coming up
his new movie coming out as well he does
that's coming i just saw right there
it's upcoming movie
you know who's got a movie coming out
that you was talking [ __ ] on
justin timberlake oh i love justin
timberlake uh
it's like uh did you see it's called
palmer
netflix no they just dropped the trailer
for it yep
and he's bro he's gonna win an oscar off
this one really why are you talking
trash on jt huh no i'm not just saying
no he
when he was filming it him and his
co-star this uh
woman were recorded in new orleans where
they were filming the movie holding
hands kind of like being very touchy
feely
and this is why his wife jessica biel
was pregnant
and so he had to come out made an
apology yeah
jt ain't cheating on her we don't know
that i don't
i don't think he is i don't think he's
stupid enough to hold hands with a girl
in public
even if he is also i don't think he can
but he does he does get i think
i think he was being drunk and feely
that's what i think like yeah
yeah like yeah like your chest getting
grabbed yeah i think they did this movie
and they [ __ ] each other's brains
outside
the whole jt yes he faithful dog
yeah you're right you ever heard the
song mirror you're side eyes
yeah uh-huh whatever you say i think
yeah this happens in the movie
the trailer chin we can't play it
obviously
he gonna win he gonna win something off
this yeah another move palmer
palmer this acting is horrible no it's
not really
have you seen that well really hollywood
begs to differ yeah
but he's not there makers beg the
difference yeah you get roles like that
yeah i'm about to get a role in the
horror film
okay a horror film chappelle you seen
that one movie that he starred in uh
with the oh it's called there's
something about time just in time
what time was it like in time
i thought it was a dope movie it was
alpha dog alpha dog was great
again social networks social networking
he's a great social network yeah what
was the other one we said he did really
good in
uh was a bad teacher bad teachers he was
good he's a business
let me see the trend yeah let's see this
trailer this isn't
him this is him as a lead now yep
look at that right there all right so
that first look
you tripping dog yeah you crazy you are
crazy like a 2021
shout out you ain't never going to get
anywhere hating on people man
how are we hating on them how are you
going to say that man is not talented i
do not say anyone talented i say he
can't act
exactly what i said and a lot a lot of
people can't agree he's a great musician
you
never know i've never heard anyone here
are you serious
okay a lot of people when we had that
episode a lot of people agree with me
that was like bro you know
okay you tripping he'll get nominated
that [ __ ] looks fantastic
i'm gonna watch it i'm gonna watch it
i'm again i'm gonna think you're gonna
win a grammy for your big sean this
that's us playing are you seeing peanut
butter falcon is that me he's another
shot no yeah solid buff is great check
that out yeah
just change subject don't know
that's it all righty shout out to jt
that movie looks fantastic i know
that's great jeremiah watkins yeah
listen to his album now
yeah now album and special is on amazon
prime right yeah you can flip it over
you get to see
my mom him and his mom mama on vito's
pizza that's one of my other favorites
on los angeles
yeah you came back found it wow shout
out to bootleg pizza fantastic pizza
a 50 what five five zero four west pico
boulevard that's great
la this crew is in san marcos texas uh
all four shows almost sold out i think
some were already sold out january 29th
through the 30th
san marcos texas the crew will be there
thick boy gear
thick boy and specialized collab drop
drops next
friday next friday the specialized uh
collab drops all right thickboy.com for
all your stick boy needs
uh that's it jeremiah we love you man
yeah love you guys
yeah thank you so much so fun so
chappelle ac whoopi goldberg
and i got on the jordan once uh
blues blue blues clues uh edition
yeah all right
here's ella all right malik b
aka rat williams and i got a rap i got
the ovo pens on right now
and i got the cactus jacks travis
scott's you know i mean the fours right
here
nba too yeah
i've never had so hard i know right
jeremiah watkins born and raised kansas
rocking the nike
air force ones in sevens
those are the native they have american
vibes
colorado buffaloes these are those
air max off-white
tangerine with the tan
okay